bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
und es ist endlich soweit unsere gebete
wurden erhört ich weiß hier gebetet hat
ob ich habe gebetet dass alle versuche
aus
unser tägliches brot gib uns heute
unseren job x-server so bald wie möglich
wieder und leute die gebete wurden
erhört ist hat funktioniert alter und
das feiern wir direkt mit einer maschine
und weg geht direkt rein kommt nicht
kriegsspiel und lehrer mögen werde es
mir egal
und während wir hier mal überprüfen ob
noch alles beim alten ist werde ich auch
ein paar fragen beantworten die mir
gestellt unter dem hashtag question
es kam selbstverständlich wieder auch
einige fragen zum thema wie viel
verdienen youtuber ich muss mal gucken
ob ich darauf eingehen lauf des videos
weil es mir nicht ganz sicher ich habe
eigentlich überhaupt dazu mal klartext
zu reden weil alle youtube dass die
titel schreiben
omg so viel verdiene ich dann sage ich
einfach nicht wieder verdienen so
bullshit leute seht ihr das hier das
bild sieht richtig richtig sexy
ausfindig und zwar rocken wir heute ein
merkel pack animierte von to sneak
preview in kombination mit dem ziel
durch schreibend medium scheder version
1.4 und ich muss sagen minecraft bei mir
noch nie so gut ausgesehen
auf jeden fall das war als kleiner tipp
falls ihr sohn mittelguten rechner ab so
wie ich ist es glaube ich die empfehlung
so diese kombination sie
zusammenzustellen
ich bin mega überzeugt und ihr seht oder
es nicht aber mir gedroht haben findet
ihr dass es ein animated pack ist und
die schwerter ziemlich ziemlich geil
aussehen
hier habe nämlich 1 was man auf zack so
sind die schwerter aus und wir legen los
mit der ersten frage des heutigen tages
tiefstand von jenny rp die hast du mal
max eine freundliche haus gespannt und
ja gut erstmal fall dieses nichtwissen
max ist natürlich mein bruder mein
kleiner bruder und es gibt immer wieder
geschichten von leuten die ihren brüdern
irgendwie mädels ausspannen oder so ich
kann das ehrlich gesagt persönlich gar
nicht wirklich nachvollziehen weil das
irgendwo deutet das einem irgendeinen
medien wichtiger ist als der eigene
bruder nichts anderes ist es ja immerhin
ihr entscheidet euch passt gegen euren
eigenen bruder und für irgend ein
x-beliebiges mädel was wahrscheinlich
drei monaten wieder weg ist und wer das
haus laut der
hat eine sehr fragwürdige entscheidung
in seinem leben getroffen würde ich
sagen
und dementsprechend habe ich das hätte
ich noch nie gemacht also das kann das
kann ich mir persönlich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen nehmt mal euer bruder irgend
eine freundin ihr findet die folgen dann
würde ich doch niemals meinen eigenen
bruder so hintergehen der wahrscheinlich
die freundin liebt sollte man das sagen
kann dem alter so caspar geht dass man
die freundin aus spannt und ich habe
also das geht über überhaupt nicht klar
in meinen augen etwa sophie 29 s kobold
fragt wie sieht nun mit merger aus dazu
kann ich euch eine jetzt muss einblenden
und zwar während ihr euch jetzt mal ein
logo ein was bisher mein favorit ist für
die merchandise klamotten und dann
stimmt ihr einfach meinen kommentaren ab
und sagt was ihr von dem logo halte ich
finde es logo persönlich sehr cool
so zum beispiel mit einer weißen schrift
auf ihren coolen hintergrund könnte ich
mir vorstellen den meisten front und das
logo sieht so aus sagte dazu es gut oder
sondern das sind tropfen schreibt das
gerne meine kommentare was ihr davon
haltet würde mich persönlich
interessieren
ich finds geil ansonsten ja match ist
bisschen träger und ich muss auch sagen
ich habe einfach ziemlich ziemlich
verkackt arbeitest organisierenden
letzten zeit als es gibt nicht so viel
neues dazu die zu dem thema ich wollte
ich einfach mal das sagen sie dazu sagt
dann thomas thema guten alten eisen
ich töte ich nie beschlossen und ist de
la luz ist fragt glaubst du an den
heiligen krieg
stella ist von auge zu auge muss dir
sagen wenn ich an den heiligen riedbaum
glaubt ist meinen augen kein mensch lang
lebe der riedbahn der fucking weg vom
alter wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist
es der riedbaum wahrscheinlich ist das
so der gott der uns alle helfen würde
die welt vom untergang retten wird
im jahre 2016 wenn donald trump die
präsidentschaftswahlen den usa gewinnt
ich bin auf jeden fall in belieber
belieben
in dem gebiet baum selbstverständlich
hat mich gerettet als ich komplett was
ziehe ich glaube sagt er ich glaube es
hackt okay jetzt aber ganz schön ein
bisschen uns umziehen
nein also kann es gut aber wir können
natürlich alter gg wenn man auf die road
wechseln will und einfach scheiße pack
classic
was ist deine lieblingsmusik erstellt
question fragt florian ebt von flo ich
momentan wieder extrem viel hip hop muss
ich sagen hat letztens wieder angefangen
mit mask and absoluter klassiker und
dann habe ich auch zum ersten mal in
meinem leben kann us- gehört und ich
muss sagen republik ist gar nicht so
schlecht also kann man sich wirklich
durch ausgeben
die sache ist ich werde die ganze zeit
abgestoppt ich würde jetzt zweimal
abgestaubt als einfach aber so
dankeschön
vielen dank dafür aber irgendwie von
alter da kommen einige leider wirklich
so fällt abgestaubt um antwort ja
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ein
dreier-team habt ihr die offen alter
[ __ ] nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
muss man schon so läuft das hier mal an
also das einfach aus japan hier kleiner
mann und pvp xm und ja mister lollipop
am besten gleich auch dazu noch besser
shader und texte packs und einer
beschreibung vor das interessiert wie es
im nächsten jahr wieder haut rein
macht's gut und ja ich komme nicht mehr
in die kamera